hey youtubers it's Charlie this is gonna
be my Walking Dead episode 12 video just
careful for spoilers if you haven't seen
it yet saviors vs. survivors anybody
that makes it out alive gets some of
Carol's cookies speaking of which new
round of the giveaway starts now all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave a comment on this video it's a
$20 Amazon gift card so here we go top
10 WTF number 10
Carol is a mom just doing mom thinks
making cookies doing some grocery
shopping doing laundry my mom makes the
best cookies just put them in your mouth
[ __ ]
I love the way Carol is with this guy
that she's in a relationship with
speaking of which WTF when did this
start do you think of me as a mother no
you're definitely something else all of
Carol's scenes in the first half of the
episode were super cerebral how do you
think it is that I do these terrible
things she's a mama bear and bears will
rip the [ __ ] out of you if you come for
their Cubs and didn't you love how she
put that last cookie on Sam's grave
number nine the Lord and Savior brick
tries to sell the group and Morgan wants
to bargain with negan first if they had
actually run into negan in this episode
I say that would have marked him for
death he would have been prime candidate
for Lucille but everyone's on board you
don't have to like it you just have to
do it Rick is now in this rarefied air
we he's a total badass but it's hard to
tell him from a villain just because
he's so quick to violence we gotta kill
em all that's how we survive that's how
we keep this place going I love the way
the show plays with visual metaphors too
like you can always say Jesus Saves
because we have Jesus on the show now
but Rick is like the Jesus Christ figure
here with his head in front of this
giant cross here he's like the evil
Jesus or the devil in disguise
number eight WTF Carol can't sleep she
starts writing in her journal these are
all the people look the markings are all
about the people that she has killed
there's Karen and David Lizzie and mica
you start to see the emotional weight of
the things that Carol has done she's not
a complete monster I mean she is the
Terminator Carol is totally the
Terminator but it's taking its toll on
her which is white number 7 WTF she
refuses to let Maggie help when they
need to no you're not going anywhere
you're supposed to be a different person
I think it all has to do with Maggie
being pregnant where she not pregnant
yeah they would have both come running
number 6 WTF let's grab us a fake
Gregory I love the way they lined these
fake Walker heads up in Rick just
opens up on one of them like it's no big
deal Dan these saviors are scary but
they ain't got [ __ ] on you so casual
such a badass cannot wait to see what
happens when Rick finally meets negan
number five WTF a knee takes fake
Gregory gives him to the Savior's ship
brain needle dick go down in rapid
succession one of my favorite moments
though was when one of the Savior's took
the Gregory head and just started miming
his mouth great use of walker puppetry
lil [ __ ] broke my nose cranking up the
kill montage number 4 WTF Rick kills the
first one in his sleep just nice and
slow like go to sleep forever so
hardcore so intense the number 3 WTF
actually the same type of kill only Glen
lands his first real kill Glen has
actually never killed an actual person
before and I love the way they played
this scene because it felt so intense
like that other guy was gonna wake up
before it Heath could do it you could
definitely see on his face that he
wasn't gonna be able to do it but the
Walking Dead is really great with the
way it holds moments like that you just
you hold your breath waiting for
something to go crazy and then his Glen
slowly sinks his knife into that guy to
you exhale you're like oh thank god and
then he looks up at the board at the
collage of people that those two dudes
have killed probably does not make him
feel any better about killing those
saviors in cold blood number two WTF
next big kill Gabriel is a badass now
just reciting Bible verse all freaky
Quentin Tarantino like as he kills the
Savior in number 1 WTF Maggie and Carol
get captured by the Savior's and if you
didn't recognize the voice that's alicia
witt i don't know if she's playing
someone from the comics yet but we'll
find out next week when we hear her name
you might remember her from the last
couple of seasons of justified but the
big WTF now is should carol have let
Maggie go to help pregnant Maggie who
probably should have gone in the first
place in based on the teaser for next
week's episode sounds like she's gonna
be holed up captive with the Savior's
for a little while whether or not we
actually run into the main group of
Savior's what we've seen is really only
the communications tower and that's
probably just a small portion of them so
let me know in the comments what was
your favorite moment actually forget
that what was your favorite kill in this
episode tickle n have the best kill or
is it Gabriel have the best kill I would
say Gabriel's was more badass but
Glenn's was more in
hence cookies for everyone now I felt
like even though not a whole lot
happened in this episode in terms of
plot like they didn't really push this
Savior's plot forward that much the
pacing and the intensity was totally on
point and I always love when they mess
with the intros like they used that
really happy music over Carol's mom
montage with moments like her
splattering Walker blood all over her
white blouse like ah nuts so it manages
to both be a hilarious episode and crazy
WTF at the same time that is the Walking
Dead when it's at its best when you
alternate between laughing and screaming
the real debate that I think most people
are having now is is Rick a bad person
and would Morgan's plan have worked
trying to bargain with negan they
probably would have had the same deal as
sell top give us half of everything and
we won't come after you if you've read
the comics you know some of the terrible
things that negan does please use
spoiler tags if you want to talk about
them specifically in the comments
because it doesn't just end at giving
half your supplies negan is also the
world's best bully the way the producers
describe the TV show version of negan
and it's also kind of true the comic
book version is that he is the perfect
bully he's charismatic he's funny he's
not an idiot it's very easy to dismiss
bullies that are total idiots it's way
worse when a bully is super funny and
super compelling he really is for all
intents and purposes the diametric
opposite of Rick the evil Rick very
good-looking very charismatic very funny
when he wants to be the negan doesn't
have any kind of aspirations like Rick
does Rick wants to help people he wants
to create a life for everyone negan
doesn't care about any of that and it
seems like what everyone's thinking is
is that we won't see negan till the last
episode but the producers did say that
he might show up sooner than that so I
am pumped everyone pray to Jesus which
reminds me congratulations to this
week's giveaway winner Anna B you win a
$20 Amazon gift card be sure to private
message me on the back end of my channel
so I can get your contact details
everybody go eat some cookies now it's
actually Girl Scout cookie season right
now so some of you might actually be
eating cookies as we speak why you guys
wait for next week's video to post you
can click here to learn all about my
favorite game of Thrones foreshadowing
moments Game of Thrones almost back and
you can click here to learn all about
the deleted scenes the bonus features on
the star wars DVD that's coming out soon
thank you so much for watching everybody
let's high five I'll see you guys
tonight